Parliament adopted its position on the  next long-term budget pushing for more  funding for youth research jobs and  tackling climate change around 94% of  the EU budget goes to citizens regions  cities farmers and businesses Chancellor  of Germany Angela Merkel is the 12th EU  leader to debate the future of Europe  with Emme peas and the EU Commission  President jean-claude Juncker she called  for a United European approach to  migration Parliament President Antonio  Tajani announced Icelandic film women at  war as the winner of the 2018 lux film  prize the three finalists were  translated into all 24 official EU  languages new Telecom rules will boost  superfast 5g networks and cap prices for  calls between EU countries members also  voted to create an eu-wide emergency  alert system Parliament voted to make  50% of new buses electric from 2025 as  part of targets to reduce co2 emissions  across the EU